if you go prone Esports try not to win a
car that's because it seems like they're
cursed for example in 2017 at
dreamhack Masters Las Vegas CS player
Taz was told by virtus Pro's then owner
that he could have a Mercedes if the
team won and they actually did
but the car was like a cursed artifact
according to members of the roster it
divided the team
and there's more in 2016 rocket League
Pro chronovi won a BMW in an E3
tournament and yeah his team did go on
to win rlcs that year but almost
immediately after the team collapsed and
then there's perks who was a part of C9
and got a really nice gift in 2021.
obviously perks went back to the LEC for
the next season and not a single DOTA
player who won a Mercedes for being an
MVP at an ESL one event went on to win
T.I that year so what do you think our
car prizes cursed